i did bring up the kaylee mcnamee story
she's a boss
she's great kaylee mckennady is one of
the i as far as i know the best press
secretary i've ever seen
i agree under obama i can't remember the
guy's name but it was just boring
nonsense
it was it was decorum it was like we
were pretending to do things
yeah and that journalists pretended to
do jobs and it was just the stupidest
whatever anyway
under trump it's been a bunch of
different press secretaries it's been a
weird and wild ride
but then he hires kaylee mckennany and
she is
it's rock you know you don't you know
unshakeable but you know what i think of
yeah have you ever seen scott pilgrim
versus the world yeah you know the fight
scene
with um uh what's her name ramona
the woman the sa which one like she's
the girl that scott pilgrim wants to
wants to date or whatever okay
she pulls out that giant sledgehammer
and she's fighting with it
okay that's what i think of when i see
kayla mckenna answering the questions
for the press
it's like the journal no it's a giant so
the the journalists are like actually
kaylee you know defending the police
doesn't really mean defunding and she
goes hold on and she pulls out a giant
sledgehammer and she's like
she's like smashing things no but what
she really does she pulls out a binder
and she goes i'm glad you asked
she could do that and we've seen the
photo of our binder and you can look at
all these tabs
of all these different sources and
citations and i'm like
she knows she's got her stuff anyway so
so today she she had a press conference
and she's talking about you know
all these different things calling you
know answering questions and right near
the end
um someone asks her a question and she's
getting into it she finishes answering
the question she goes all right
now i'm going to talk about defunding
the police
and just as she's getting into that on
fox news
they they cut their they get out of
there they go back to the
do you know why what did they say i i
she
i didn't really i i didn't pay much
attention to fox news i just saw that
they
someone pointed out to me on twitter
that that that happened and i was like
wow like so what and i actually was
watching the direct feed
so i watched the whole thing through and
then i like someone was
posting that fox news cut away and i'm
like really like everything that she was
saying was like legit like i had to go
back and like look
and and that's what these these graphs
are here so yeah so adam posted the
graphs
so here's the important context we've
got another really sad story we're going
to highlight in a second and i'm being
very delicate with it
that's why we're starting with the stats
first okay kaylee and that that's why i
want to bring up yeah good point
there's an activist who lost his life
who is shame a leftist
defund the police all that stuff someone
shot him in the head
it's a damn and so it's it's it's really
sad and so this is why i think it's so
important we take these stats seriously
to understand exactly what's going on
adam has these clips from
they're from just the news and this is
so so what is this this is what fox news
cut away from
it's she was posting these you know
she's got the two screens on either side
of her she's talking
and she was just talking about what
defunding the police actually has shown
to the cities that have actually done it
and here we have the minneapolis
city council member saying um this is
one action of many that we need to take
on the road to a more equitable and just
system that keeps people safe
and they unanimous they had a unanimous
vote to dismantle the police completely
and the result has been a 94 increase in
homicides
compared to last year now now first i do
want to mention
it's hard to know if these are directly
related
however in new york city we can say yes
check this because
they got rid of they got rid of
specifically
now look they say i'll read this one
they said
defund nyc city council cut police
budget by one billion dollars
the result is a 177 percent increase in
shootings from july of 2019
however the defund resulted in them
reassigning 600
anti-crime uh police officers
specifically charged with stopping gun
violence and then all of a sudden
murders spike
and the people locals in new york are
saying please give us these cops back
we want them patrolling our
neighborhoods we want them doing this
it kept things safe chicago actually
rolled out a new unit to deal with gun
violence
crime went down wow who would have
thoughts i'll tell you what man
i am not the biggest fan of a lot
of what we see from police departments i
agree i think it is fair to say
that we could have respectable reform
discussions and respectable is the
important part because
when you treat it's ridiculous to me how
people treat cops
in as a whole as you know bad there are
a lot of bad
cops especially with all the
unconstitutional edicts that's been
going around
and the arrest of small businesses and
the seizing of weapons not a fan of
these
and i think people should call them out
but the institution of policing itself
is fine i've i've had slightly more
negative experiences with police than
positive
and i'm not immature enough you know i'm
i'm mature enough to recognize
well i know they they do their thing and
you gotta it's it's it's
it's a part of how the system works and
society works i would say
80 of my interactions with police have
been solid
and i i personally know policemen and
they're great people
smaller towns the better in my opinion i
met i mean i
we both lived in new york and i had good
experience with cops in new york also
yeah the cops i've had bad experiences
also but
okay right there's bad people out there
there's good people out there you know
i've had bad experiences with the
the clerk at dunkin donuts once i've
actually had more negative experiences
with like
starbucks than i've had with cops to be
honest there you go it's a thing that
people don't understand but i think it
has to do with the police
the police authority like you know how
think think about a a
restaurant you've gone to like a fast
food restaurant you've had negative
experiences man
i tell you what there was one one
mcdonald's to go to they got order wrong
every single time it was frustrating
they'd argue with me
they would refuse to correct and you
know yeah
i didn't i didn't call for abolishing
mcdonald's i get it though police are
maybe you should have tim yeah well no
but but it's fair to say the police you
can't just
get rid of you know you can't stop going
to the police you have your local police
department
and so i think there's there's reform
discussions that are fair what's insane
to me is that they pulled the trigger
before having actual discussions well
like what's going on in seattle you know
they're they're getting rid of the
police they're abolishing the police
right i think that's what they voted for
so one of the they issued the bill so
far okay so so it's
it's up to you know whether it passes or
not we won't know yet but
it's regardless they're they're putting
into place community-led
counselors what else what is exactly are
they doing i don't remember exactly what
their plan is to replace the police
yeah with gender affirming praxis well
i'm not kidding i know i know we talked
about the other day so some of the
things i disagree with
as far as what they're replacing the
police with but a lot of the things that
they're doing
are actually legitimate and i don't
understand why they want to get ri
get rid of the police and and why
wouldn't they
try rolling that in because when that
comes in and if that works
then they can defund the police but
we're seeing people are getting killed
no no it sounds like what you're saying
is fund the police
i am think about it absolutely i am you
take the cops you have now all right
here's what chicago did they created a
new unit called the critical incident
response team
specifically dealing with protests
rights first amendment issues crime has
gone down
i'm not going to pretend like all these
cops are doing perfect jobs but that's
what's happened so far
so the point is if you get a bunch of
cops who are
who are specially trained and you have
let's say you want
gender affirming praxis social workers
whatever you call it
they literally called it you know what's
it called gender forming practice
practice whatever
let's say you want that okay you give
more money to the police
but wait they create a gender affirming
praxis unit
and and now when specific incidents
happen they will send
those officers out boom it's that simple
that's right and that's what i am that's
what i've talked about
talked about with like a civil guard
perhaps yeah and it's not too dissimilar
to what a lot of people are saying with
social workers or whatever
i think the problem is people come out
and say
why don't we have social workers respond
to homeless calls into mental illness
calls and stuff like that
that's a really good idea we should add
a mental health care response unit to
our local police departments or at least
one specialist
who can direct and be in charge of
specific incidents and help reduce
you know the use of lethal lethal force
loss of life
the last thing we should do is be like i
know let's get rid of
all the police and replace them with a
bunch of health care workers
yes the bank is being robbed and they
walk up wearing their pink you know polo
shirts saying
we just want to talk to you are you okay
bang bang bang and they run away yeah no
terrible
they're defunding they're defunding the
police they're getting rid of these
units that's what they've done in new
york already
okay we we shouldn't be voting to
abolish police
we should be voting to create the things
that people think will work
and then talk about reassessing how
we're spending money on police and
whatnot
but it's it's it's like we talked about
before you have you have malpractice
lawsuits with doctors
a lot of them yeah a lot abolish doctors
right yeah sure why not no
buy their own logic why not right that's
that's why
they want to get rid of the police and
i'll tell you what man
people say yeah but cops do all these
wrong things you know listen i
understand you get mad at cops for
giving you tickets you get fines
you get you know stopped or whatever it
can be annoying and i do think that
there are some cultural issues and in
many departments we've seen it
there's also the fact that the media
shoves down all of the
the worst of the worst the worst of the
worst stories that come to light and
that's all that they push is
they're they're pushing uh terrible
stories and that's it
because that's what gets the clicks i
know people who hate their dot who like
who hate their local doctors yeah
they want to go somewhere else same
thing with schools i had a bad teacher
abolish all schools
okay no no no no hold on we can do other
programs to fix school and without just
shutting the schools down
school choice yeah yeah i think it's
great binary
let's pull this story up yeah because
this is this is this man that's kind of
horrifying
student activist killed in shooting
weeks after protesting police presence
in cps chicago public schools
caleb was a son a brother a community
organizer and a neighbor
his light potential had been
extinguished at the hands of gun
violence like so many others in chicago
all right i'll tell you what this is
this is popping up a lot of people
there's a lot of mean people on the
internet man yeah there is and they're
gloating about this and they're they're
you know serve you right well also the
nasty stuff nah man when people lose
their life it's sad
always always if this dude had you know
legitimate points about not wanting cops
in certain areas yeah i'm willing to
hear what he has to say
definitely the fact that he lost his
life i think is a horrifying tragedy
and now i don't get to hear what he has
to say i can look back at his old old
comments
but i will say this does show in my
opinion
there is an importance to not abolishing
the police
to put it simply yeah chicago's got
serious problems with gun crime
i mean it's not even i don't even need
to say it they call it chiraq
so this dude man this is sad they found
him lying on the ground
like why would why would someone do this
you know it's it's
it's yeah man let me read a little bit
a student leader with a youth activist
group that has been prominent in the
push to remove police from chicago
public schools died sunday morning
after he was shot two days earlier in
the west rogers park neighborhood
kayla breed a 17 year old junior at
mather high school on the north side
just weeks earlier had spoken about his
traumatic experience with officers at
his school
at a news conference with public
officials ahead of a board of education
vote on a 33 million contract with
chicago police department
late last week officers found reed lying
on a sidewalk about 1 pm friday in the
1900 block of west granville avenue
authorities said he had been shot in the
head and was taken to saint francis
hospital in evanston according to
chicago police
reed died at the hospital at 6 40 a.m
sunday according to the cook county
medical examiner's office
police have not announced an arrest reed
was a student leader with the group
voices of youth in chicago education
which has been one of several student
groups advocating for the removal of
officers from cps
voice coordinator maria de guillo said
reed was a dynamic and fearless young
man who did everything he could to teach
people how to love and value black lives
he was also the heart and soul of a
campaign to remove police officers
from chicago schools they didn't find
him in a school all right
but i'll tell you what this is just
another story and the reason i want to
highlight it first and foremost is
to say you know with all due respects
man being from chicago
no i'm i'm sad to hear it i think i
think anybody who wants to fight for
what they believe in peacefully like
this guy was speaking up and doing his
thing i respect that 100
and i'm i am deeply angered and troubled
by what's been going on in chicago for
so long one of the reasons why i don't
ever want to live there again sounds
like a really amazing guy to be honest
and they have serious problems gun
violence and if if there's anything that
comes out of this
i think we can point out two really
important things chicago has a
horrifying history with their police
john burge read that story about that
guy man crazy yeah but also
you got gun violence problems man and i
shouldn't have to be reading a story
about an activist
advocating for you know police reform or
whatever removing police from the
schools hearing the story he did not die
in a school so let's let's make sure
that's clear
it's not an instance where he was like
you know abolish all the police
he was saying get the cops out of cps
according to the story and then he was
found dead some somewhere else
yeah what what the reason i'm
highlighting is just to point out
there are good people who don't deserve
to die i mean people in my opinion don't
deserve to die
and we in certain circumstances i think
to be fair
but here's a story about a dude who
should be alive right now why was his
life taken
and what are we gonna do to make sure
doesn't happen again and i hate to say
it but this means properly trained and
well-funded police
it does it absolutely does i completely
agree with you and it means if we have
bad cops we need to reform these things
chicago i mentioned this several times
had to disband a police unit that was
invading people's homes and robbing them
yeah chicago's got problems man that's
why i look at this and i'm like dude
this is what we need we need to fix
police not abolish police we need to fix
the union
system because that's also a big problem
and we got to fix the
if if they get fired for being a bad cop
they shouldn't be able to be a cop
anymore
period we got to fix that there's
definitely no issues that are out there
that we have to fix
and i think we also need i think there
is a serious problem it's a class issue
of people who don't know
how to deal with police in in terms of
like when you're getting stopped you're
getting detained yeah i hear all the
time from these lefty
lefties they weren't reading they
arrested me and didn't read me my rights
and it's do you know anything about
police that means nothing means
literally nothing
reading someone's rights is is for their
protection to launch a formal
investigation they can arrest you they
got to say anything to you
these people clearly don't know anything
about what their rights really are
and the proper ways to deal with police
and too many people i see especially
you know having grown up on the south
side ego problems yeah it's like the
cops
is jamming them up so they would rather
scream and yell and and cause trouble
than to be calm and reasonable and deal
with it but i do think there's a class
issue there in that you know i was lucky
enough to have a dad was a firefighter
who told me here's what you need to do
when you're you're dealing with cops a
lot of these younger people in chicago
don't know
and so they're like don't you tell me
what to do no it's even worse than that
we're seeing little
little kids carrying signs that say f f
the police
and it's like they're they're like
six-year-old children being told that
carrying signs that say that you gotta
get the magamini i i know i just want to
finish this
look guys i'm going to put the beanie on
now you know we're talking about
something right here so no beanie no
peace the chest
yeah i know i see it right i see it but
there you go
but that's what they're being
indoctrinated as as children
to to hate them you know it's like
the the whole like hip-hop is teaching
it too it's like it's part of
their culture now to hate the police but
it's like
they're they're there to protect you
it's part of the democrats culture to
hate the police
you're right i tell you man right it's
the democrats culture i was talking to a
friend of mine who lives in a sparsely
populated
low crime area and and she's telling me
we got to just get rid of all of them
i'm like so easy for you to say you live
in the middle of nowhere
your back your backyard is the woods so
yes when you have people show up to your
house
or you know when there's crime in your
area you live in the middle of nowhere
you don't you don't notice these things
you have no crime
well it's not the same for the suburbs
and it's not the same for the cities
so it's really easy for these people to
say and i'm like and why would you want
to anyway you don't interact with the
police yeah well they're bad and i'm
like
when you talk to the cops they're just
talking about the the media
clips that they're there that is shoved
down their throats
from the media that just wants to
portray the police as being bad
to whip up emotions and especially
in an election year when they're all
about to go down they're trying to get
as many people on their
side as possible using emotions while
it's backfiring it's backfiring yeah and
it feels like they're
it's too late to turn back for them so
they're trying to lean in as far as they
can and it's not working anymore thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8 p.m if you want to
catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you